It's time for Drew's News.
Your daily rocket straight to planet Good News.
And with me at the desk, co-captain of the news ship,
Rossy Ross Matthew
Hi!
Reporting for duty!
Hi, Drew.
Hi, Rossy.
Well, we're gonna get right into it today.
And first stop for anyone out there online dating.
And I bet how many of you, show of hands,
are online dating right now?
Oh, the rest of you are lying.
(audience laughs)
(Drew laughs)
(Ross laughing)
Keep your hand up.
Be proud. Why not?
Hey, listen, you can't fight city hall.
It's the current state of the world.
Well, this is exciting then.
Dating, you're still looking for that perfect first date
for the online dating world.
Well, there's a first date suggestion now.
It comes from Amy Nobile,
a dating coach in New York city.
Insider talked to Amy, and she said
that the first ideal meetup is the 30 minute coffee.
She says this is a mini date.
It's a perfect screener to let you know
if you want to do more.
Sort of like a dip in the toe in the pond,
instead of going for a whole hog skinny dip,
taking a nibble of that cheese
before eating the whole wheel.
Rossy, in your single days,
did you have a perfect first date formula?
(Ross laughs)
No.
No, I didn't really date until I was 28.
I just was like, I didn't.
And then I got in a 10 year relationship.
And then I got out of that and then I started dating.
And, you know, it turns out I was good at it.
I really was.
And I would have a lot of dates.
I wasn't like, you know, I wasn't hooking up,
but I was dating.
But I'll tell you, I don't think the coffee date
is a great idea.
Really? Why?
Well, a couple of reasons.
One, if you meet up and it's great,
like, I suggest going to a happy hour
because if it's great, you could slide that date
into a dinner, right?
And if it's horrible, you're drunk.
Right?
(audience applauds)
But can I ask you?
I mean, are you a coffee date kind of person?
Well, I don't drink coffee,
so there's a problem right there.
Okay.
You know, I date occasionally.
You know, some are good, some are bad.
I never let the bad ones like bum me out.
I'm always like, oh, okay, whatever.
And then the good ones, you know, well,
I guess they haven't been that great.
(audience laughs)
(Ross laughs)
But I do think the act of dating is fun.
Yeah.
And what worries me, is that people
go on a series of dates and they think like,
you know, I just don't want them to ever get defeated.
And I also think that like getting ready for the date
and just like honoring yourself,
and having a moment like in your closet getting ready
is like the fun part.
And you should play music, and just enjoy the whole ritual
of like, what human beings do.
We're so weird.
We're like, let's meet up and like assess each other
and sniff each other out like a bunch of deer in the field.
Right?
And then if we like it, we'll do the next date.
Like, it's just a part of the ritual of being alive.
It should be fun.
It should be fun and light.
And I think it's fun.
I think dating is totally a blast.
Oh, me too.
I loved it.
I mean, I'm done dating cause I'm engaged now.
So we do dates, but...
(audience applauds)
Well, thank you.
But I'll tell you, dating was work.
I realized I wanted a relationship.
I wanted marriage.
So I put in the effort.
I went on a lot of dates, Drew.
I am going to admit this.
I even did a couple times.
Two dates in one night.
I know. I know.
I know.
Oh, no, you didn't.
Yeah, I scheduled a happy hour and then I was like,
okay, I gotta go.
Another date, but it's because...
I know, I am hearing myself say it.
Your first date guide just got a little more interesting.
Yeah, because you have to put in the work.
You have to do it.
It's like trying on jeans.
You don't stop till you find the right pair.
Well, also, let me see a show of hands.
How many people date really to find somebody,
and like lock it down?
Raise of hands.
Not that many in our audience.
How many people go on dates to live the fun ritual of life
and enjoy themselves?
More.
What are the rest of you doing?
(Ross laughs)
(audience laughs)
Are you married?
You've already-
They're married.
They're not dating.
You're married.
Okay, well, it took a date to get there I suppose.
Or not.
All right, well, I think this is a rich debate.
Ross, your story.
All right, well, next up it may not be the best place
for a first date, but a new study reveals
Americans love to hang out in their cars.
Mm-hmm. Yeah.
The Good News Network reports that a survey
talked to 2000 drivers, and 58% of them said
that they have had the best moments of their lives
in their car.
Whoa?
(Drew laughs)
The best moment of your lives in a car.
58% of you?
I wonder, I bet 58% of people lost their virginity in a car.
Which is why.
Now it's starting to add up.
I'm not a mathematician, but ding, ding, ding.
48% said they love to talk to themselves in their cars.
42% said it's a great place to cry alone.
Wow, all I'm doing is driving.
Drew, what are you doing in your car?
I also enjoy eating while I drive.
I don't know if that's the safest thing to say,
but it's true.
I'm from California and you drive everywhere.
And so I would multitask by like, you know,
eating a sandwich or a burrito like while driving.
So I feel very comforted,
and that's when I listen to like talk radio
because I don't wanna listen to music and eat.
I hate eating while listening to music.
I do because-
(Ross laughs)
That's the most ridiculous thing I've ever heard.
I don't like it except for Billy Holiday.
It just got weirder.
(Drew laughs)
(audience laughs)
You don't like eating and listening to music?
No, music is too sexy, or sad, or excitable.
When I'm eating, I just wanna focus.
(audience laughs)
I got your back even if it's insane.
Totally.
Okay, and finally, we're hopping over to New Zealand
for this next story.
The Washington Post reports,
a preschool has a very special traffic safety officer.
Her name is Henry and she's a hen.
(Ross laughs)
That's right.
Starting at 8:00 AM, Henry dons her tiny safety vest
and roams outside the school.
Making sure cars drive nice and slow around the students.
Talk about a happy car story.
She makes sure nothing goes wrong,
and that's what I call a real HHIC.
Is that a head hen in charge?
Bingo.
I'm proud of you.
I wonder if this hen had any formal training,
or if she's just winging it?
(audience laughs)
(Drew laughs)
(Ross laughs)
(audience applauds)
Don't you have hens at home?
I have six chickens, actually.
That's my real chickens.
Those are yours?
Yeah, on the left is Boy Hunch,
then Sparkles, Pepper, Percy, Ramona.
Really?
Yeah. Absolutely.
Would your chickens trying anything like this?
Are they too chicken?
Yeah, right.
I don't know if I would trust them
with all due respect to you chickens.
I'm not sure I'd let them, you know, be in charge of safety,
but I don't wanna underestimate them.
You know that old joke how did the chicken cross the road?
Or why did the chicken...
Oh, I'm screwing up your joke.
(Ross laughs)
Gee, Ross. How?
It's not even worth it.
(Ross laughs)
(audience laughs)
Is that the joke?
No.
Oh no, you gotta do the joke now.
You remember that joke,
how did the chicken cross the road?
How?
In a reflective vest.
(Drew laughs)
(Ross laughs)
Protecting school children?
In New Zealand?
(upbeat bright music)